screen junkies asked dr. Adam
Friedlander to analyze action movies and
tell us what would really happen to your
favorite characters today's patients the
Wet Bandits combines up testicular
hematoma frontal cephalo hematoma
vertebral fractures and posterior rib
fractures hip and pelvic fractures scalp
hematoma and concussion cervical spine
fracture Harry is dead
facial and cervical spine fractures with
second-degree burns Marv is dead second
and third-degree burns contaminated
puncture wound
spine and rib fractures third-degree
scalp burns land heart lacerations and
glass foreign bodies spine and rib
fractures bad cop
Oh facial fractures spine and rib
fractures facial fractures sternal
fracture with cardiac contusion
help shoulder dislocation with humerus
fracture skull fracture with epidural
hematoma Marv is dead Oh facial fracture
with epidural hematoma Harry is dead
spine and rib fractures nasal bone
fracture nasal bone fracture
pelvic and spine fractures with internal
bleeding
skull fracture with epidural hematoma
Marv is dead skull fracture with
epidural hematoma Marv
is dead skull fracture with epidural
hematoma Marv is dead skull fracture
with epidural hematoma Marv is dead
penetrating rectal trauma penile
puncture wound spine and pelvic
fractures
multiple fractures and internal injuries
Marv is dead concussion with skull
fracture and possible epidural hematoma
Harry is dead spine and rib fractures
testicular rupture anterior full-body
contusions
severe burns and cardiac arrhythmia Marv
is dead third-degree scalp burns airway
burns with solid and hollow organ injury
Harry is dead
multiple spinal compression fractures
Marv is dead rib and finger fractures
multiple facial and c-spine fractures
Harry and Marv are dead spine and
scapula fractures massive internal and
external injuries Harry and Marv are
dead
rib and facial fractures with lung
contusions
rib fractures multiple impact injuries
Harry and Marv are dead internal organ
rupture and traumatic brain injuries
Harry and Marv are dead
alien bacterial infections including
histoplasmosis final report 9 Harry's
and 14 morphs are required to complete
home alone 1 & 2 kid what movie would
you like to see us analyze next tell us
in the comments below and we'll waste a
professionals time to find out and as
always please subscribe